Why Does Rudolph have a Red Nose?
Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer was created
by the department store chain Montgomery Ward
as a way to save money on one of their annual
Christmas promotions.
The year was 1939; Montgomery Ward, at that
time, gave away coloring books to try to get
more shoppers into their stores during the
holiday season.
Up to this point, they simply bought these
coloring books to give away.
In 1939, in order to save on the price of
the books, they decided to try to make their
own.
Enter Robert L. May who was a copywriter for
Montgomery Ward in Chicago and was apparently
known by his peers to be good at writing limericks
and children’s stories.
Because of this, he was chosen to write a
Christmas story to be used for this promotional
coloring book.
May was very small as a child and was often
picked on, so decided to make it an Ugly Duckling
type tale, which he wrote in the same verse
as Twas the Night Before Christmas.
While he was writing, he tested various versions
of the story out on his four year old daughter,
Barbara, until he and she were both happy
with the results, at which point he presented
it to his boss.
May’s boss did not like it at first, due
to the fact that he felt a red nose implied
the reindeer had been drinking.
However, once it was partially illustrated
by Denver Gillen, who worked in Montgomery
Ward’s art department and was a friend of
Mays, his boss decided to approve the story.
In the first year after its creation, around
2.4 million copies of Rudolph the Red-Nosed
Reindeer were given away.
By 1946, over six million copies of the story
had been distributed by Montgomery Ward, which
was particularly impressive considering it
wasn’t printed through most of WWII.
After the war, demand for the story skyrocketed,
receiving its biggest boost when May’s brother
in law, radio producer Johnny Marks, created
a modified musical version of the story.
The first version of this song was sung by
Harry Brannon in 1948, but was made nationally
popular by Gene Autry’s 1949 version, selling
2.5 million copies of that version in 1949
alone and has sold to date around 25 million
copies.
Despite the fact that May created the story
of Rudolph and it was wildly popular, he did
not at first receive any royalties from it
because he had created it as an assignment
for Montgomery Ward; thus, they held the copyright,
not him.
In a rare move for a business, in 1947, Montgomery
Ward decided to give the copyright to May
with no strings attached.
At the time, May was deeply in debt due to
medical bills from his wife’s terminal illness.
Once the copyright was his, May quickly was
able to pay off his debts and within a few
years was able to quit working at Montgomery
Ward, though just under a decade later he
did go back and work for them again until
retiring
in 1971.